The quickest scene to render is the one without any lighting at all, right here
on the lower right-hand corner. These objects just use a solid color and so
little detail is visible. The second fastest to render is here in the upper
left, as the objects do not cast any shadows. Note how details get lost near the
front edges. It's hard to tell where the floor ends, and the top of the outer
wall begins. The next fastest to render is here in the lower left. This one has
shadows, which take longer to render. Shadows help us a bit in telling how
surfaces are related to each other. However, everything in shadow looks the
same. Since we're computing only light that directly hits these surfaces. The
slowest rendering is here in the upper right. It's also the highest quality, as
light bounces off the walls and into the shadowed areas, so giving them some
definition.